the coronavirus quarantine is a great
chance to tap your musical talents or
read a book or bake a cake but it's not
fun and games for everyone
lockdown can quickly become locked up
for victims of domestic violence
we know lock downs and quarantines are
essential to suppressing coffee'd 19 but
they can trap women with abusive
partners over the past weeks as economic
and social pressures and fear have grown
we have seen a horrifying global surge
in domestic violence calls to abuse
hotlines and Police Department's are
spiking around the globe I'm Ben for
zulan when the crisis broke out a
policeman told me he was worried about a
sudden rise in domestic violence he was
right it's happening behind closed doors
in homes around the world and was
already a big issue in Lebanon she
simply wanted to live a happy life with
their four children again without fear
or pain in mid-april this 35 year old
mother left her old life and fled to an
emergency shelter for women here with
their children she's trying to process
the pain she experienced for more than
nine years she was mistreated and abused
by her husband and a father in law in
the first few years he used to hit me in
the face in the shoulder or stomp on my
legs
later he beat me with sticks and iron
rods so badly that I had severe swelling
and intense pain I developed problems
with my bones and joints because he
always hit me in the same places in
[Music]
Beirut sexual abuse within the family as
a widespread problem and often a taboo
topic now the situation has gotten
dramatically worse due to the corona
virus epidemic
Lebanon's government has introduced a
nighttime curfew most shops and
businesses are closed and people are
expected to stay home
they're behind the facades there have
been some terrible scenes of domestic
abuse it got increasingly worse he
became more and more violent and he knew
that I could not go to my parents
because of the night that curfew
everyone stays at home
the kovat 19 pandemic came at a time
when Lebanon was experiencing its worst
financial crisis in decades the currency
is struggling unemployment is on the
rise and wages have been cut in some
cases up to 50% aid organizations say
many men are bringing their frustration
and anger home with them and taking it
out on their wives most women who get in
contact with us are victims of domestic
violence the situation is getting worse
because of the curfew and economic and
social pressure especially because the
perpetrators are always at home now
that's why the Abad organization is
stepping up its activities that hung
banners throughout the city calling for
an end to the violence and offering a
hotline to get help it's an attempt to
encourage many woman to break from their
silence and it's working the group is
getting more and more calls so far this
year they've already received twice as
many calls as in 2019 just in the last
month we had about 300 calls 240 new
cases the others had already made
contact with us and more and more women
want to come to our shelters this brave
woman is one of them she's refusing to
take the abuse any longer and is now
filing charges against her husband a
clear signal in a time of crisis the
Europe head of the World Health
Organization says the agency is deeply
troubled by reports of increasing
domestic violence and is sounding the
alarm if lockdowns who were to continue
for six months we would expect an extra
thirty 1 million cases of gender-based
violence globally beyond the figures
only a fraction of cases is ever
reported
only a fraction that's deeply troubling
Junko Gupta joins us from George Mason
University's College of Health and Human
Services a lot of us live in loving
homes and can't imagine the fear and
pain of abuse or being trapped with your
abuser give me an idea of what that's
like for these women yes it's it's very
scary and isolating and the figures that
the W show Europe the sound bit that you
just played they're alarming but they're
certainly not very surprising for those
of us who study the epidemiology of
violence against women and those who
provide services we know from patterns
following other crises such as natural
disasters or the Ebola epidemic that
violence against women does increase
following these large-scale crises these
figures are really incredible I mean the
w-h-o is saying 60 percent of women just
in Europe are affected I mean every
second woman right and this is on the
backdrop of violence against women
specifically intimate partner violence
which is violence that occurs within
romantic relationships even before this
coronavirus crises it was quite high
global estimates from the whu-oh show
that one in three women will report
experiencing physical or sexual violence
from a romantic partner at some point in
her lifetime let's return to Hans Kruger
from the w-h-o for just one moment
listening to this there are examples
where countries have addressed this
Italy has an app to ask for help without
a phone call pharmacists in Spain and
France can be alerted through code words
hotels in France and Belgium have been
converted to shelters Greenland has
limited the sale of alcohol to make the
home environment safer for children let
me explain that last point nearly a
third of
people in Greenland suffered sexual
abuse in their childhood this crisis is
in covering one horror after the next
how do you keep kids safe if their
parents are the perpetrators yes
it's very difficult for children as well
because the people in their lives who
would have been in a position to help
teachers pediatricians those types of
things are all closed now so I think one
important thing to keep in mind and this
is true for both violence against women
as well as violence against children is
that family and friends can continue to
try to maintain connections
just because we're physically distancing
doesn't mean that we can't have a social
connection we can all try to become
familiar with help lines that are
operational either through phone or by
text we can also develop code words with
family members so that if somebody is in
trouble they can signal through a code
word just similar to the clip that you
just played about the code words being
used in some countries but but is that
it they the only options family and
friends I mean what about people who
don't have family and friends right so
health care workers obviously they are
overwhelmed at this point but they can
certainly become familiar with the risks
of shelter in place and lockdown for
both violence against women and children
and refer to resources telehealth is
being used more frequently for
appointment so exploring how telehealth
can be used to make those referrals in a
safe manner as well jong-kook hope to
thank you very much for being on the
show today thank you now to your
questions on the corona virus is our
science correspondent derrick williams
what
think will happen after lockdown is a
second way very likely well no one can
predict the future I mean who would have
predicted that we'd be here a couple of
months ago but a second wave is
certainly possible
um what's still up in the air is exactly
what form it could take and in a great
article I read this week some top
experts from the US talked about what
might happen next
after mitigation measures are eased now
their models are based on data from past
influenza pandemics they hypothesized
three different scenarios in the first
the current spike in cases of kovat 19
would be followed by a series of
repeating smaller waves every few months
for the next couple of years right into
2022 in their second scenario we would
see a fall this summer but kovat 19
would come back with a vengeance this
fall and winter after that big spike in
cases there would be smaller spikes in
2021 with the pandemic only starting to
peter out in late 2021 in the third
scenario they postulate which they
called slow burn there isn't a big
second wave that would mean we're going
through the worst of things now and
depending on mitigation measures the
infection will remain with us in the
future but without a clear wave pattern
one way or the other they say we have to
be prepared for at least another two
years of significant kovat 19 activity
if antibodies only work for a limited
time is there a risk a vaccine will only
protect you for a limited time yes there
is that risk
although antibodies are only one part of
the immune response when you contract a
disease or are given a vaccine we're
still on a very steep learning curve
when it comes to questions of immunity
to Co vat19 we aren't even sure whether
some or all of us really do become
immune after we're infected or if we do
become immune how long that immunity
might last with other coronaviruses we
develop immunity but it isn't permanent
so yes it's possible and even likely
that any vaccine against this pathogen
will not provide permanent protection
from any future infections but at this
point even if a vaccine provided us with
a year or two of immunity that would be
a big wind can sunbathing help in
coronavirus treatment or prevention as
spring turns to summer here in the
northern hemisphere could increasing
radiation from the Sun help slow the
pandemic that's a big question
seasonality is common for many
infectious respiratory diseases although
the exact reasons for it are kind of
hard to untangle experts agree that UV
light plays a role but a range of other
factors do as well including the fact
that you're you're simply less likely to
catch co2 19 outdoors than you are in
enclosed rooms low vitamin D is another
factor that some studies say makes you
more likely to catch certain respiratory
infections and your skin produces
vitamin D when it's exposed to UV light
so short answer there's no evidence
sunbathing can help treat the disease
but but spending reasonable amounts of
time sunbathing shouldn't increase your
risk of getting it and it might even
lower your risk if your vitamin D levels
are low assuming of course that you
don't break any lockdown rules and you
also pay attention to social distancing
measures
you